hello and welcome to the hans kim
studios
up here in new york city overlooking
manhattan
manhattan
uh it's a beautiful day to be
broadcasting and
celebrating
the day uh the year of no abortion
number three
or four or five
or six
we're having a good time we're
celebrating the loss of freedoms and
stuff
uh we're having a good time and just
relaxing
so on the topic of news today
there's a lot of news going on
one such piece of news item
is uh
first
cassidy hutchinson stands by her
testimony amid pushback
so the january 6th commission is still
ongoing
that is a very good thing
uh we should
investigate what happened on that
fateful day when our democracy was
ruined and tarnished by a bunch of
out of shape [ __ ] and douchebags and
farmers and rednecks and
middle-income people who want to
preserve their wealth and keep this
system going
even though it's clearly not working
uh this is live yes i'm live right now
for the people that are listening at 6
53 p.m central time in on june
29th 2022
so we're just going to be talking about
the news and figuring out what is really
going on
in the news today
so payment data could become evidence of
abortion now illegal in
so this is just abortion people worried
about abortion
they're gonna they're gonna be talking
about abortion for a while now
abortion is cool
um obviously we're sliding into
a theocracy we're sliding into some
1950s
1800s
uh what's that hulu show
where they were like little pilgrim hats
the women were little pilgrim hats we're
sliding into that
we're sliding into
um
[Music]
whatever that's called
mistresses club or whatever
and the world that the conservatives
want to create for us is horrible and
not very free and
a very horrible place that they want us
to live in
and we need to keep progressing to the
future and ignoring the religious idiots
and the racist
people who don't even realize that
they're racist i want to preserve this
system that is racist
um because they're
benefiting from it or
like these people are so [ __ ]
tuned and ready to live in this world
they're like perfectly created to
survive in this
[ __ ] that we have
uh in this scrappy world where
i'm gonna make it [ __ ] you get out of my
way they're all like that and they're
perfectly designed for this [ __ ] world
and they don't want to create a better
world because they're like well i'm
already made for that this shitty world
i don't want to create a better world
that i'm not designed for
um
handmaiden's tale yes handmaiden's tale
i got a planned parenthood punch card
hans kim channel in chat
uh long time listener first time caller
are you a news reporter i thought you
were a comedian now william montgomery
that's a comedian
someone talking [ __ ] already
um yeah i mean
he's a very funny comedian am i a news
reporter should i not talk about things
that are going on
well why don't we just
jump into the land of fancy oh dogs that
eat chocolate and have 14 years
let's just come up with crazy ideas and
images
and that will be more up
taryn hill's speed
taran hills he just wants
wacky fun
[Music]
oh
what do we have here a dinosaur eating a
tarantula with that is boat they're both
purple
dinosaur let's let's put on something
terran hills will enjoy
dinosaur cartoon
bart
this is what
taryn hills thinks is comedy
this is is what you want taran hills
whoa
comedy
this is this is what [ __ ]
this is the bottom of the barrel type
[ __ ] that
that you get with uh
you know
some hacks
i'm not gonna name names
i miss the old hans making out i miss
the new hans making out i wish i wish i
was making out two buddy
um
the older i become the more realized
other isms
are
democracy's greatest exports
uh the old man the old man is imparting
us with wisdom let's all listen to his
misanthropy
and condescension
our democracy otherisms
is democracy's greatest export otherisms
what is an otherism the others are the
problem
well i'm sure that that's annoying to
people that are the problem hans i'm 23
with 20 with little savings on the verge
of quitting my low paying job and
chasing my dreams what advice can you
give
my advice is to quit your low paying job
and chase your dreams which you've
already done
so i would say bravo i would give you a
little clap
um you know in the uh modern times it's
not that hard to survive i mean it's not
easy
uh but it is relatively easy to survive
so if you can guarantee your safety and
survival then i would say chase your
dreams
um i mean if you're living in a caveman
time and you had to hunt for food i
wouldn't be like go just you know lay
around and think of funny little jokes
this is a modern society and modern
societies should be full of people
chasing their dreams and not just
struggling to survive
we should create more awesome things
that are awesome
and less things that are just survival
and just doing things because it's
whatever what's up hans hope you're
having a great day thanks my dog almost
ate a reese's on the bus yesterday
um
i'm sorry that you have a dog and you
took him on a bus
what do you think about pee pee
pee pee i like poo poo
poo poo pee pee
comedy guys let's do some comedy whoa
poo poo in my pee pee hole and tacos and
butts
um
but yeah i mean i would say chasing
dreams is ideal and
not chasing dreams is
what our grand great grandparents had to
do to get us here so if you don't chase
your dreams you're making your peasant
grandpa's
sacrifice worthless they sacrifice
they've toiled for their king so that we
could have a modern society and now
you're using our modern society
to
to [ __ ] all with
you're just using our modern society to
fart around with
and we are at the promised land we are
at the place where we don't have to just
survive and so we should take advantage
of that
so yeah hopefully you're doing that
um
uh i just joined in time tacos and butts
would you get two women pregnant if they
were married and wanted you to
why would it why would it be two women
just theoretically would i get women
pregnant if they wanted me to
yeah i mean it'd be cool as long as i
didn't have to sacrifice anything i
would get anyone i would do anything as
long as it doesn't cost me anything but
um yeah if i have a little baby running
around i'd feel responsible
i'd want to take care of it district
attorneys like this one in texas are
vowing not to prosecute
abortion
abortion
district attorney jose garza
pictured in austin texas in 2021
um yeah you shouldn't prosecute people
for killing their babies because babies
need to be killed you can't just have
every baby born
you need to pick and choose which babies
are born you know like all these [ __ ]
conservatives
love the spartan society of like just no
culture and just pure aggression and
violence so much
they killed their babies the spartans
killed their babies you want to be
raising all these
soy boys and peanut allergies
up to full adulthood don't you want to
create a rough and tumble society
i think those conservatives those
military conservatives are
just on the back seat right now they're
they're letting the uh religious nut
conservatives take charge on this one
they're they're supporting them of
course because they're it's owning the
libs and they support that
um
but uh yeah i don't
you you're gonna create a weaker society
if you just have babies pop out all the
time you gotta like be careful
and pop out babies at the right time
when you're ready for it but you know
like that's not what they want they want
to have babies all the time coming out
of every hole
they just want babies to be everywhere
and everyone to have babies all the time
i'm getting this new rice cooker
dishwasher combo she arrives from
thailand this sunday
classic joke
rice cooker dishwasher yeah like i got
my dishwasher's broken his name is jose
or whatever
all the crosses in front of church were
my babies
i saw they found your semi-truck in san
antonio hans
yeah because i'm
shuffling smuggling migrants across the
border
do you believe in ubi
yeah i mean i think ubi is like
a patch
on a broken system it's like patching a
dam
i don't think it's the solution i think
the solution
is you pay workers
what they bring into the company
and you get rid of upper management as
much as possible and like bloat
and you pay workers a percentage of what
they bring into the company and pay them
accurately and fairly in a mathematical
way like we need a computer to be like
this mcdonald employee has brought in
this much and not just people at the top
taking as much as they can in paying the
people that actually do the work the
minimum amount possible
i think it's just greed i think people
just take as much as they can and then
they give minimum wage employees nothing
and in a world where the upper
management
are paying people as little as possible
and taking as much of the profit as
possible
the only
way to fight back against that is with
organization collective bargaining
uh strikes
and since americans don't do that
because that's for [ __ ] and that's
not what
jeff bezos did to get rich
then we have a world where the upper
management has the upper hand and they
dominate and they kill us all
um
[Music]
yeah i mean ubi is not ideal what's
ideal is paying people fairly for the
work they do and
people being uh adequately compensated
so that you don't need ubi you just need
to work like five hours
a week to survive since we live in a
modern society you should be able to
bring in a lot of survival coupons with
five hours of work
like back in the day you have to work
700 hours a week or whatever and now
it's slowly getting less and less until
soon we're just gonna have to like flip
a switch
and then we're gonna be like oh we got
hundred thousand dollars for flipping
the switch
um but yeah i mean it's important to pay
people fairly and workers fairly but we
don't because
workers are
the support system to america's elite
which is the upper class which is what
america is designed for
how do i make my parents proud
you change what their definition of
pride is
you turn your parents gay and then
they'll have pride and then you can make
your parents proud to be gay
just get them to suck dicks and lick
clits
and then they can have pride in that
uh
uh getting this new
if i couldn't have killed the three kids
i didn't want i couldn't have had the
three kids i did want
well you're still taking the bus with
your dog jimmy stealth experience so i
don't know if
killing the three kids and having the
three kids you did want is working out
for you maybe you should um
maybe you should kill your kids and live
a better life
get a car
he's not andrew yang yeah hello but ubi
is something to consider i think it's
better than what we have now where
people are in the streets and homeless
and people working 80 hours a week to
feed their family i think we just need
to give people money because we have it
and we need to uh stop suffering once
everyone stops suffering then we can
figure it out
everyone stop suffering here's some
money stop suffering he was funnier when
he was poor now that's what you want
because you're
poor but yeah i don't know it's too
early to tell if i'm funnier now or if i
was funnier back in the day
but i do have a bigger platform and a
bigger opportunity to be funny so
i have more practice being funny and i
have a larger stage and more it's more
set up for me to be funny uh back in the
day i was being funny for like
two dudes on a couch
at a shitty open mic and people that
weren't listening to my jokes
soon computers can do all labor mental
and physical yeah and then we can live
freely unless you think people need to
be enslaved so that they don't blow
everything up
i don't think people need to be enslaved
i think that people um for the most part
uh won't blow everyone up i mean look at
how we treat people now and look how
many how few people want to blow
everything up if we treat people shitty
right now and there's this few domestic
terrorists and
you know crazy antifa terrorism and like
all the [ __ ] blowing up imagine how much
fewer terrorists there's gonna be if we
actually treat people nicely and
good
and there's going to be a lot of good
goodness in the world which country
um
[Music]
well
what about once when you don't need
workers
then i guess you need ubi
then i guess it won't even be a question
it'll be like star trek you don't need
money you have what you need and it's
not even a thought it's not even like oh
this is ubi or not ubi it's like we have
this stuff why wouldn't we give it to
ourselves
it's like
if you need to make people suffer so
that they invent things so that people
don't suffer then what's the point of
making things where people don't suffer
if we have to make people suffer
to get stuff that prevents people from
suffering why don't we just cut out the
middleman and just stop the suffering
and then deal with the
slower amount of inventions that we get
be like hey we could be having more
inventions if we made people suffer but
we don't need inventions and stuff
the most important thing should be
having less suffering and less people
dying and their moms
crying and [ __ ] i can't wait for
robinson community
miscarriages are also illegal now
manslaughter
yeah don't bump into pregnant ladies or
you might be killing them i mean if it's
growing inside of you you should be able
to kill it if it needs you to survive
then [ __ ] it
it's optional but if it's out of the
womb and it doesn't need you to survive
then
you can't kill it
if it needs like
the mother to take care of it and stuff
then uh
you
you need to take care of it or the state
you need to give the baby up to someone
who will take care of it
if it's on like a ventilator
and it needs to uh be on a ventilator
then you can't unplug it because a
ventilator is not a human
it only costs money to keep it alive but
if it's relying on you and inside your
body
then it's your body and you should be
able to kill it like if i
crawl up inside you and i start living
inside of you and you want me out you
should be able to pull me out and then
if i die then that's
on me and if the baby is gonna die if
you pull it out it's more humane to kill
it inside the womb than to pull it out
and let it dehydrate and
you know
die outside of the wood so yeah abortion
should be legal if it's the mother's
choice
women are wonderful beautiful creatures
and they should be able to decide who
lives and dies especially if it's
connected to them and if it's their
child i think that's a good system i
think we need to democratize
uh abortion and be like hey if you don't
want it then you don't then you don't
you shouldn't have it
no one else should be able to make that
decision i think if everyone is on their
individual self like
power is decentralized and you're gonna
make better decisions which country
invented collective bargaining i think
collective bargaining was invented by
the first mob
the first mob of antelope or
zebra that were like [ __ ] this guy
why are we listening to him why doesn't
the larger of the classes simply eat and
kill the smaller of the classes that
mean
that makes sense you want it
performance-based i can't wait until
robots wipe my butt trying to get out of
the system not be a part of it a little
a lot of words to explain oligarchy just
curious if you're in the legal
in one
in one the illegal states what's the
penalty for an illegal abortion death in
texas
probably penalty for everything here is
death
i think that the penalty for aborting a
little baby
should be freedom you did the right
thing you killed a baby it was hard and
you did something good for society
i can't wait to get hooked up to the
metaverse all day long
uh are you saying people who grieve over
miscarriages are overreacting over
nothing
now it can be sad if you are gonna if
you're planning on having a baby and
then it dies and you're like
but it shouldn't be it legal or illegal
to be like you have a miscarriage and
you killed it
um
if you're
like i'm not trying to police people's
emotion i'm not saying you you should
never cry
if you cry that's 14 years in jail but
if you don't cry at all then that's the
way you're supposed to do it
uh i haven't been seeing polish since
the days of kill tony of the story he
was good okay thanks good to know
that play still has comedy
you're saying um just noticed
hans got some nice dsl stick sucking
lips
okay
um i like the idea you did with the kill
tony remake for dating i think it's a
good twist for a different angle of live
podcast yes giggle and then jiggle
for a brave moment
i was watching a video about the big
mill vanilla
scandal i'm out
okay um
but yeah
there's a lot going on in the world
right now
the migrant deaths
too man charges the police find possible
link to texas migrant deaths without
america
what would the guardian cover
it's like they're in a civilized country
over there and you in the uk
and they look at us with our crazy ass
system and like all this crazy [ __ ] that
we do
and they're like oh isn't this
fascinating that's the best the best
isn't to live in america and have to
experience it and be afraid of this [ __ ]
uh but to live in a civilized country
where they have health care and look
look at the crazy [ __ ] we're doing be
like whoa
they're like trying to they're trying to
keep mexicans out of the country that is
raping their country and
depriving them of economic resources
so they have to come over here and
sometimes they have to do it in a very
haphazard way and they hire a truck
driver that
doesn't open up the air hatch
men were detained leaving home listed on
registration paper for abandoned trailer
truck worth 53 migrants were found dead
see that's the good thing about uh you
know having a record and like
keeping track of [ __ ] is that you can
find out who was supposed to be in
charge of [ __ ] and it's like if you
weren't
going to take responsibility you
shouldn't assign this [ __ ] you signed
this piece of paper and now it's your
fault then it's like oh [ __ ] i signed
this paper and i got to make sure that
my mexicans have air holes
or at least
texas have been charged possessing guns
at a federal authority continue to
investigate
so that's what they charge them for is
for the guns for some other [ __ ]
that's not directly related it's like
we're gonna use the law roughly and just
like figure it out and be like
we're gonna we're gonna be like oh you
we're gonna use whatever we can to
charge people that we want
you deserve to be charged so we're going
to find something that you did wrong
in san antonio
for really contained the bodies which
had been discovered abandoned in an
industrial area of the texas city
agents with the federal bureau
i like the british covering american
stuff because they're like more outside
observers they're like aliens they're
like whoa look at this
this is the information that we have
americans would be like oh they were
illegal and they were not supposed to be
here and
this is so [ __ ] up and stupid that
they're trying to get over here
uh or they're like oh they were victims
they were so beautiful
local police were stalking the building
at theirs and they saw the dulunas
getting to ford f-250
that's mexicans having an american truck
they're like [ __ ] yeah we love the
american culture
we hate mexicans too
they
uh killed more mexicans than people that
actually kill hate mexicans
uh which is filed incorrect
there's also a pistol and
how do you get arrested for having a gun
in texas
uh so they have visas that expired they
had guns so they're like
you can't have guns if you're on visas
that are expired
yeah if you kill 50 people people are
gonna crack down on you but you can't
charge them for what they actually did
that was wrong you had to charge them
for guns
like you [ __ ] up on the gun thing like
who gives a [ __ ] get them for the uh for
the 50 people that were in the [ __ ]
truck
just open up a hatch can you imagine
being in there just suffocating it's hot
as [ __ ] right now in texas too
without permission why didn't i have to
add without permission
authorities said three people whom
police detained within hours of the
body's discovery were suspected of
planning to smuggle the mino grants
across the southern u.s border without
permission can you do that with
permission
um
uh what if the babies unionize
that's a good point the babies should
unionize and then they can fight for
their rights and be like we don't want
to be aborted
the mothers will be like
well
i own the means of production
i own the means of producing babies and
i decide that you shouldn't be in here
i'm gonna forcibly evict you from the
premises that i own i have bodily
autonomy and you're not supposed to be
in here
they're like
well
if you forcibly evict
babies out of the womb then we are going
to
uh stage a sit-in and
you know start kicking more there will
be 10 more kicks in the belly if you
forcibly evict
a small percentage of babies
and the mothers would have to bargain
they'd be like okay we'll just abort
five percent of the babies
but unfortunately babies are not smart
enough they don't have the power the
brain power to be able to make that
decision because they're not human yet
and you should be able to kill them
it should be able to kill babies so that
we can have a better society overall it
is the most effortless most uh least
amount of collateral damage
involved in killing someone and uh
nobody really gives a [ __ ] about fetuses
you have to make an effort you have to
imagine
caring about a fetus you're going out of
your way to care about fetuses go adopt
a baby if you care about babies so much
uh and then if you adopt a baby and
you're still against abortions then
you know adult more babies until you're
like okay we can't adopt that many
babies babies are not that cool
and you'll be like okay we gotta kill
some of these [ __ ]
eleven more of them so some people
survived
i wonder who survived like what kind of
body do you need to survive a hot
18 wheeler
that didn't know the chain desert
well you know overall the problem is
that we raped mexico so that we can make
more money off of them through nafta
and people are suffering in mexico
economically and then they come to the
country that is doing well because we
are raping mexico and all the loot is
stored here and if you just have a
country
that is not economically deprived and
the victim of economic rape
then people won't want to come here so
bad and you can keep them over there and
they can be happy
instead of
having to cross the border
and chase the money that was
taken from them and the resources that
were taken from them
so stop [ __ ] up mexico for your own
profits stop
going to foreign countries and
installing your corporations in there
let countries rule themselves
and then you won't have this horrible
[ __ ] happening
but if you continue to rape uh mexico
then people are gonna do horrible [ __ ]
to get over here
and you are responsible for that
for the profits that you extracted from
mexico
we in america are living off the backs
of third world countries
and uh
and we are responsible for this horrible
[ __ ] coming over here and americans are
like that wasn't me man i wasn't the one
that did it but if we don't take
responsibility for it who will no one
else has the power to change [ __ ] like
americans do
americans don't want to feel bad even
for a second
they don't want to feel anything they
just want to feel the best emotions as
much as possible all the time
which is super unhealthy and then when
they crash they crash hard because
they're so afraid of feeling bad
just feel bad it's not that bad to feel
bad i feel bad all the time and i'm
happier than you
just like being like oh this sucks we're
responsible
and then if you just feel bad about it
that'll that'll impact your
actions in the future and hopefully
you'll be a better person
should we give mexico land back
uh
i mean we can give them back new mexico
i don't think we're doing much with that
we can give them back
well why don't we improve mexico first
and make it like a thriving country and
then people won't be so [ __ ] afraid
to join mexico but i think ideally what
should happen is we should destroy
countries all together and we should be
independent little fiefdoms and
connected through love and
you know humanity
and love of each other and empathy
so we don't need countries
where we're like we will love people
within this line anyone in here i love
everyone outside i hate
instead of that we can just love people
and be nice to them and trade with them
and hope for their continued success
because it impacts us
and be aware of how we're all connected
so that we don't need countries
to rigidly and bureaucratically
distribute love
we can just do it
uh
[Music]
organically within our own selves and
our own
our own genitals and we can all [ __ ]
each other
even if we're not in the same country
stock indexes on wall street and it must
be lower wednesday after another choppy
day of trading as the market head
market heads towards its fourth monthly
loss this year
oh no
who is that tick-tock woman that was
like
the stock market is just a graph of rich
people's feelings it's all about
confidence
i have a lot of confidence today ah look
the nasdaq went up i have a lot of
confidence
we
need some reparations from the china's
as well as whites
who is we mexicans what did
china do to mexicans
who was impacted by china and the whites
vietnam
are you vietnamese vietnam
hands is a good
but we get to keep tony
have you ever been to mexico
uh no i've never been to mexico
we should micro dose all the time and be
empathetic with one another
that's true
forty of the dead so far were male and
thirteen were female
i wanna know who the survivors are so
that i can mimic their body type just in
case i ever find myself in an 18 wheeler
be like oh you got to be a small little
dude who you know it takes little sips
of air
um but you know in a in a
tractor-trailer full of 50 people 53
people dying that's like that's a
nightmare that's traumatizing for sure
these people 11 people are now gonna be
out in the world dude what the [ __ ]
that's so horrible to be trapped in a
tractor trailer and not be able to get
out
and air conditioning as it traveled
through temperatures approaching 100 f
i bet everyone was naked i wonder if
anyone [ __ ] or if they were too busy
dying to really get it on there's not
enough lube everyone's dry it's like
don't get too wet we need to save this
water up so that we don't dehydrate
um
uh more checkpoints for large trailer
trucks on well traffic roadways in an
effort to limit episodes like well one
and monday you know what they need is
they need a [ __ ] hatch
but even a hatch isn't good enough what
you need is like to outfit these [ __ ]
trucks with little compartments that you
can open from the inside but if you do
that then it's more likely to be caught
because you're adding [ __ ]
but yeah i don't know how that happened
that they they got into san antonio and
then they just abandoned it who the [ __ ]
maybe it was like some trucker that
didn't even know he was carrying humans
which is like the ideal way to do it you
know plausible deniability
but then it's like take the truck to
where it was going like why did he just
abandon it on the side of the road why
didn't he just open the door like was it
some psychopath or was it just
forgetfulness
it's just
not an ideal situation
but the real problem is that we have a
land of wealthy connected to a land of
poverty and if that's the case then
it's like a low pressure system and a
high pressure system air is going to
want to flow to the area with low
pressure
and that's what's happening there's a
lot of pressure in mexico and they want
to go to america because there's low
pressure what we need to do is create a
low pressure situation in mexico but we
won't because that would require
long-term thinking and thinking about
everyone and not just ourselves which is
what not something that we are willing
to do we choose not to do that
anyways uh deutsche bank is trying to do
this guy's just copy pasting wall street
journal [ __ ]
uh cp uh are you afraid that if you go
to mexico you can't get back in no i'm
not really afraid of that i'm asian as
[ __ ] i don't belong there they don't
want me there like what is this
pale chinky-eyed mexican doing here this
is not the aryan mexican
this is not our ideal version of
ourselves we want to send them back
go back to once you came you
pale ass
little mole rat of a mexican
and did you come with rich people good
sex joke
um when
when i had i came up with the rich
people good sex joke when i had good sex
and i was like man now if only i was
rich then everything would be perfect
it's like there's not much that i need
now
besides rich and then i was like whoa i
wonder what rich people say after they
have good sex
uh and then that's where the joke came
from if you want to see that joke google
it youtube it i'm not gonna say it here
it's just so that there's less clips of
me saying my jokes
but
yes good sex is awesome unfortunately
rich people very rarely have good sex
because they are living in a corrupt
society they are the peak of a corrupt
society they
they channel all the filth
of our society so they have a lot of
filth in them they're like a tiger in a
poisoned ecosystem they're eating poison
deer and they're getting rich in
in immoral ways so that
they're not healthy themselves
um
[Music]
yeah so rich i don't think rich people
have that good sex
that good of sex i think it's very rare
that rich people have good sex the best
case would be if we lived in a beautiful
vibrant society
and rich people
uh could have good sex guilt free
unfortunately that's not the world that
we live in
um
coyotes do this because then they get to
keep all the money and they don't have
to do any work
yeah i mean i don't think that coyotes
really left the truck in the middle of
san antonio
because they didn't want to
um
because they wanted to keep all the
money they already have the money they
already got them in america all they had
to do was open the door and set them
free
if they keep them locked up then
uh
it gets discovered
um
and it creates a big news story there's
more attention drawn to it
and then there's extra security at the
checkpoints for their [ __ ] asses
so it's not good for anyone this is not
a good story for anyone involved this is
inefficiency
in the worst way possible
but yeah i mean i think it's horrible
what's happening and i think that we
need to treat our neighbors better
because if this is how we treat our
neighbors what is the incentive for
people to be our allies if this is how
we treat
people that work with us
like if this is how we treat our allies
and there's not much incentive to
work with america if this is how we're
gonna treat them so why don't they just
do whatever the [ __ ] they want
do
uh conservatives have conservative sex
jokes
yeah they're like being conservative is
the best
i'm looking for my monogamous partner
and then when i find it i'm going to be
super unhappy
isn't it great to do what you're told to
do all the time
thinking for yourself is not necessary
you just got to do the classic thing
that everyone's doing
uh did you ever have
magentosis
nope
is that your americanized name or do you
also have a korean name this is my name
let's just
you can just pick a word that people is
going to associate with you and just
make people call you that a name is just
a name it's doesn't have any special
meaning
even if you think it does
it's just a word it's just a noise
people make for you
and uh you can choose one that has
meaning behind it but really doesn't
matter um but yeah that's my name that's
what i associate myself with
and i don't really want to think about
it any other way
all these [ __ ] people what is your
real name [ __ ] you i told you what you
need to know this is all you need to
know
about me if i want to tell you more i'll
tell you more
don't ask
but yeah i mean uh yeah this is this is
the name that was chosen for me that
i've grown attached to and that i've
associated with positive things
should i buy a tesla humanoid robot and
start an only fan of that
um but i actually have to go i have to
go do a little comedy show at the balkan
guest company starring joe rogan
and other assorted comedians amazing
uh so i hope you have a good time we're
gonna go
out and have a good time out in public
hopefully get laid
tonight ladies i am available
anyways i don't want to be too thirsty
but this
is all about trying to get me late this
is like an hour long infomercial to get
me laid
thank you guys for coming i liked how
you did rolls your rs do you speak
spanish did i roll my r's
i don't know hey five bucks keep up the
great work 4.99 what is this a [ __ ]
mattress sale
why 4.99 but thank you for the money
uh only took
40 minutes to earn five bucks
but this is actually very easy so
i shouldn't really be getting paid for
it anyways
anyways have a good night and have a
good time and remember